if There is a There is always a way bu
cümleyi bir istek varsa her zaman bir
yolculuğunu şeklinde direkt olarak
çevirebiliriz Aslında Eee ama aslında
hani cümlenin ruhunu daha iyi
yakalayabilmek adına bir niyet bir Eee
Gaye amaç varsa her zaman bir şeyler
değiştirilir muhakkak veya değişir
şeklinde çevirmek tamca daha doğru
olacaktır Eee Siirt'in Erol ilçesinin
yeşil Ören adlı ücr köyünde şu anda se
çocuğu olan bir ailenin ilk çocuğu
olarak dünyaya geliyorum e
hatırlayamadım İlk birkaç seneden sonra
şehir merkezine taşınıyoruz hala küçüğüm
Tabii Eee Ama artık 45 yaşlarındayım ve
etrafımda olanları az da olsa
anlayabiliyorum anlamlandı biliyorum
etrafında işte önlükleri okula giden
okula gidip gelen öğrenciler görüyorum
ve ilgileniyorum onlara Ben de onlar
gibi Okula gitmek
istiyorum Tab hayatın gerçeklikleri
biraz daha farklı
oluyor Hemen öyle başlayamıyorum
sonrasında ayakk boyacılı başlıyorum
oradaki amaç şey okul için gerekli olan
kayim önlük çanta bu tür harcamaları Han
neşte Ondan sonraki sene okula
başlıyorum bu arada işte eğer sabı
öğleni öğen sabahlar heam
ediyorum bu
şek
gidiyor ondan
sonra Siir O yaşlardaki bir insanın
yapabileceği bütünü işi
her
kili kar varsa
herde ve He
birç Ar İç daha haat anlamlı şeyler dah
daha şeyler y
yazı
kar falan yardımcı oluyor Neyse ortaokul
da bitiyor bu sefer İşte benim liseye
gidip gitmemem
konuşuluyor için gayet geçerli nedenler
mevcut ama bir yandan da okula gitmek
istiyorum
aslında uzun laın kısası şimdiki adıyla
olan inanç sesine işte kendi okulum Siir
ve Türkiye genelindeki sınavlar
sonrasında tam burslu bir şekilde
okumaya hak kazanan 30 kişiden biri de
ben
oluyorum ve bu benim hayatımdaki en
önemli kilometre taşı oluyor aslında
Eee liseye geliyorum Eee ilk ders ve ilk
ders İngilizce tahtada if There is a
will There is always a way yazılı Tabii
silte bizim İngilizce öğretmenlerimiz
çok yoktu ve o derslere de genelde işte
din kültürü matematik hocası falan
giriyordu Eee sadece işte Hello Hai
biliyordum bu kadar hatta onu bile o
zamanki işte filmlerden falan
hatırl O kadar kötüydü ki İngilizcem
Hani Kaç yaşındasın diye soracak olsalar
işte şeklinde cevap verceğim Yani o
kadar içer akısı bir halde neyse işte hü
hocayı bekliyoruz sınıfta H Hoca geliyor
biliyorsunuzdur ve işte filme kaldığımız
yerden devam ediyoruz Aslında çok
Sonraları Ben İngilizce özel İngilizce
dersleri verdiğim zaman hakikaten benim
de ilk başladığım nokta o oluyor
bu
inanılm yerimde oturamıyorum rahat yani
önüme Ç her şey oku ü her
Ak
at iyak bilmiyor öyle söyleyim
sadece işte
köyden
son' inancın sınavlarına girmek için Eee
geldiğim zamanlardı Aslında Eee ama bir
yerden sonra tabii o da yetmemeye
başlıyor ondan da daha fazlasını
izlemeye başlıyorsun işte E ne bileyim
farklı diller öğrenmek istiyorsun farklı
yeni insanlarla tanışmak istiyorsun e
farklı mutfaklar deneyimleyin farklı
müziklerde belki kendini kaybetmek
istiyorsun
Eee yani hani Kısacası herhalde böyle
bir insan olarak daha zengin bir insan
olmak istiyorsun ya da istiyordum e Bir
lisan bir insan hani
olabildiğince çok lisan öğrenip
olabildiğince çok insan olup e ortak
insanlıkta bulmak istiyordum kendimi
kendimce
Eee ve Belli bir yerden sonra artık Hani
yerel veya ulusal değil gerçekten de
hani küresel Global ölçekte işte
düşünmeye başlıyorsun Eee o noktada işte
hani dünya vatandaşı olmaya dünya
vatandaşı olmaya giden yolda yürümeye
Aslında bir anlamda karar veriyorum ve
onun arayışları içerisindeyim O noktada
da işte AFS sahneye giriyor
e kendimi bir anda Amerika'nın başkenti
Washington dc'de yanlarında kaldığım
Host ailenin işte Host babası Fred
Albert ilk adamı ilk adam adlı kitabı
hakkında konuşurken işte buluyorum orada
da benim hayatımdaki İşte bizim
hayatımızdaki ortak noktalar
paralellikler falan
bahsediyoruz oradaki 3 A bu arada
Amerika'ya işte ilk gidiyorum AFS AFS
sınavlarını geçtikten sonra bu arada
Amerika Dışişleri Bakanlığın verdiği tam
bir bursla Amerika'ya bir sen gip
oradaki bir ail y kalı Oradaki bir
liseye gitmeye hak
kazanıyorum O noktada ilk Gittiğim yer
asında
oluyor işte aile değiş
Dolayısıyla geliyorum orada tekrar aile
değiştirmek zorunda kalıyorum Neyse hani
bu Fred benim 3ün ve son ailem Aslında
Eee ve şey hani bir sürü sorun sıkıntı
falan filan yaşıyoruz
E bunların yarattığı Aslında bize
kattığı çok önemli deneyimlerin de
neticesinde bir yerlere geliyoruz
sorunlar sıkıntılar Bu Arada Arkadaşlar
hayatın hiçbir evresinde hiçbir zaman
tamamen Yok olmuyor bu noktada hani
benim için en azından Önemli olan şey
oluyor Hani aynı sorun ve sıkıntıların
bir daha yaşanmasını
engellemek ve Hani o yaşadığımız sorun
ve sıkıntılardan gerçekten hani daha
zengin insanlar olarak çıkmak o
deneyimleri o şekilde e faydalandırmak
AFS yu da bitiyor Ben tekrar geri
geliyorum inanç lisesine tabii Ondan
sonra da yine Hani rahat durmuyorum
hiçbir şekilde inanç lisesinde
yapmadığım aktivite herhalde kalmamıştır
işte okul gazetesinde yazmaktan Tutun da
model Birleşmiş Milletler kulübünde yer
almaya işte koruda ad söylemekten tut da
tiyatro kulüplerinde Hani oynamaya kadar
hatta Öyle ki işte bir dönem İngilizce
dersleri vermeye başladım kulüp olarak
İngilizce bilmeyen hocalar için
inançtaki iki tane fotoğraf sergisi
açtım mesela o dönemlerde Tabii bunların
hepsini hakikaten severek ve isteyerek
yaptım gerçekten yani hani o noktadaki
açlıkları bir şekilde gidermeye çalışı
ve onları işte gidermek için hep tip
şeyler yaptım Neyse işte inanç bitti
inancın diplomasını aldım ıb diplomasını
aldım hala neden bana diploma verdiler
bilmiyorum ama Sağ olsunlar var olsunlar
Ondan sonra da işte Brown üniversitesi'
kuslu kabul edilen ilk Türkiyeli öğrenci
oldum inançtan da BR giden ilk öğrenci
oldum Aslında E işte orada okurken de
hani bir sürü farklı İşte çalıştım Hani
işte aynı zamanda çalıştığımı
hatırlıyorum
okulun departmanı için kamanlık
yapıyorum kaldım y sorumlusuyum aynı
zamanda ok K çalışıyorum yani bunları
yaparken de Tab
işte farklı dillerde dersler alı çok
özür dilerim bu şey
Yapı farklı diller alıyorum bu işte
farklı İnsanlar farklı deneyimler yeni
şeyler öğrenmek istiyorum farklı diller
al tane dili aynı anda alıyorum
İngilizce fra ve Arapçayı Bu arada Hani
üniversiteye gidecek arkadaşlar varsa ki
gideceksiniz hepiniz kesinlikle üç dili
aynı anda Almayı tavsiye etmiyorum
kafamız karışıyor diller birbirine
girmeye başlıyor Neyse bunların yanı
sıra aynı zamanda işte hani sinema
dersleri hukuk dersleri alıyorum Ayrıca
yi kendi alanım olan şey ayrı bir yeri
verim Neyse Brown da bitti ondan sonra
New York'a taşındım işte New York'ta
oradaki yüksek mahkemede bir yargıcın
yanında staj yapıyorum
yaklaşık seneye yakın bir staj yaptım
Ondan sonra işte İstanbul'a temel dönüş
kararı türkiyee Döndükten son ilk 6
A
özlerdim çeviriler yapt kitap çevird
dizileri falan çevirdim bir Avrupalı
kurulu için iştee i ve dış politikası
ilgili politik analiz yazıları falan
yazdım en ni bir kurs
şk
or işin Hani beni tanımlamasına beni
tanımlayan tek şey olmasına izin
vermedim asla izin vermeyi de
düşünmüyorum aslında
Eee
yani ondan sonra Günüm çok
pard bir insanın yaptığı iş Eğer
gerçekten severek ve Hani hayatına anlam
katarak tatminkarlık duyarak bu çok
önemli bir şeydir ama hani onun dışında
hayatın hepimiz için getirdiği
gerektirdiği Bazı işte şeyler
mecburiyetler olabiliyor ve o
mecburiyetler tanımlanmak istememek
Aslında benim söylemek istediğim şey
vurgulamak istediğim nokta günümüz
Dünyası biliyorsunuz hakikaten hani
artık
çok
globalleşmesi
biz dünyanın öbür ucunda olan birileri
olarak haberdar olabiliyoruz herhangi
birisiyle çok daha kolay bir şekilde
iletişim kurabiliyoruz ve hani bunun
Tabii ki beraberinde getirdiği işte
artılar ve eksiler muhakkak ki var Ama
hani artık yaptığımız herhangi bir şey
dünyanın herhangi başka bir noktasındaki
insanlar üzerinde bir etkiye sahip
olabiliyor Yani tek taş bir yüzük
aldığınız noktada Afrika'nın bir
bölgesinde ve orada yaşayan insanlar
üzerinde bunun negatif etkisi olabiliyor
ya da
işte belki biliyorsunuzdur haberlerden
okumuşsunuzdur pasifik'teki Solomon e
şeyleri adalarının bir kısmı şu anda
tamamen deniz altında kalmış vaziyette
işte küresel ısınmanın yarattığı
etkilerden bir tanesi ya da Hint
okyanusunun Etrafında olan ülkelerin
birçoğunda çok toplu olarak insanlar
yerlerinden falan başka yerlere de göç
etmek zorunda ya Artık çok daha
birbirimizle etkileşim içindeyiz ve
Yaptığımız her şeyin Aslında Eee çok
farklı etkileri sonuçları olabiliyor Eee
Belki bu eskiden de böyleydi
ib
veç yakan
his Tam benim i
em
Hay hay Hayın olsa
Gere çok güzel nefler çok güzel Herkes
yaşamalı
yaşayabilmek anlamıyla Han tat duygusunu
veren anlam katan şey
bence hakikaten Hani dünyayı içinde
yaşadığımız topluluğu ülkemizi
etrafımızı ve
dünyay herkes için daha ii daha yailir
daha güzel daha ad
bir girdiğimiz ölçüde başlıyor Aslında
Eee yani Hani bu şey tabi
hani İşte benim yaptığım küçük bir şey
nasıl Hani dünyanın şeyini
değiştirebilir ki dediğimiz noktada o
şey değil yani Herkesin kendi
kapasitesine göre yapabildiği bir şeyler
var ve bunlar emin olun Bir şekilde
hani en azından etrafınızdakileri
etrafınızdakiler Onların etrafındakileri
bir şekilde etkileyip değiştirme
noktasında eee bir rol oynayabiliyor eee
e ve Hani dünyadaki tüm canlıların
hayvanlar bitkiler İşte
insanlar bunlar hepsi için hani dünya
daha adaletli olduğu noktada bu bizim
hepimize Aslında daha olumlu bir şekilde
dönüşü olan bir şeye varıyor inançtan
çok bahsettim farklı değil ama benim
için hakikaten çok apayrı Hani
doldurulamaz bir yeri olduğu içindir
Hani kendimizden fedakarlık yapıp bazen
gerekiyorsa o değişikliklere dünyaya bir
katkıda bulunmak em ve Hani fedakarlık
yapmak işte miras bırakmak derken ruş
olsun bizim inanç Lisesinin kurucusu
Sezar Türkeş aklıma geliyor ve Evet yani
Han hepimiz onun yaptığı kadar büyük
fedakarlıklar yapamayabilir büyük
miraslar bırakabiliriz işte inanç sesi
gibi bir kuruluşu var edemeyebilir
yoktan ama o noktada işte önemli olan o
düşüncenin ruhuna Aslında sahip çıkmak
hani çok küçük ve cü de olsa hakikaten o
dünyaya etrafımıza bir bir katkıda
bulunabilmek onun daha iyi daha adaletli
Daha Güzel olmasına bir aracı olmak
Aslında Eee yani Herkesin kendi
kapasitesine göre bu anlamda
yapabileceği katkılar olduğunu
düşünüyorum ben Eee bu atıyorum hani
Sokakta dolaşırken küçücük bir çocuğa
Gülümsemek şeklinde olabilir Bir
arkadaşınıza akı vermek şeklinde
olabilir ya da hani bundan daha fazla s
evinizden geliyorsa hakikaten ihtiyacı
olan insanları bir şekilde hani Eee
katkıda bulunmak
Zek falan gibi türü Bunların hepsi
olabilir
aslında şey demiştim beyaz yakalı Hayat
Han çalıştığım şirketin beni
tanımlamasına asla izin vermedim Hani
vermeyi de planlıyorum aslında bundan
bahsediyorum hani sadece kendiniz için
değil Başkaları için de bir şeyler
yaptığınız noktada Hayat daha şey oluyor
oluyor ger ve Han Benim için hayat
anlaman böyle küçük şeyler var ufak
şeyler var hani Eee ne bileyim Brown
Üniversitesi'ne başvuran öğrencilerin
mülakatlarını yapıyorum mesela Eee ya da
işte AFS ile yurt dışına gitmek isteyen
öğrencilerin mülakatlarını yaptıktan
sonra işte aile ziyaretlerini falan
gerçekleştiriyorum Eee yine benim için
çok önemli olan Eee inanç Lisesinin İşte
25 yıl çalışma grubunda aktif olarak
elimden geldiğince Mümkün Mertebe
katkıda bulunmaya çalışıyorum gönüllü
olmaya çalışıyorum
eee yani
etrafımızı dünyamızı hakikaten Hani
ülkemizi
çevremizi daha adaletli daha güzel
yaptığımız takdirde buna vesile
olduğumuz takdirde hayatımız daha tatmar
oluyor yani istersek yapabiliriz Bu şey
gibi hani ben İngilizce işte is diye
Tahtada yazıyor Hayatımda ilk defa
görüyorum ama ondan 3 sene sonra kendi
okulumda İngilizce bilmeyen öğretmenlere
İngilizce dersi veriyorum Çünkü orada
bir istek vard bir çaba vardı bir niyet
vardı ve o oldu yani her zaman ona
ulaşamayabilir ama en azından ona
yaklaşmış
oluz yani Han söylediğim gibi
İngilizceyi öğrenmeyi işte Amerika'ya
gitmeyi orada üniversiteyi okumayı
bunları çok istiyordum gerçekten çok
çabaladım ve oldu dolayısıyla dünyanın
daha iyi daha güzel olması için
gerçekten çalarsak
kendi iin hiç
yok Biz ben buna inanıyorum e ve Evet
yani Hani belki bunu aklımızda hep
tutmamız
gerekiyor teşekkür
ederim